joining me now for reaction has been
Shapiro editor of The Daily wire Ben I
read that and I thought that's at least
an honest liberal view he hates Trump
you can't stand Trump but going to a
rally and seeing the reaction of the
people and thinking Kamala Harris or
Cory Booker are they really gonna get
the get the Mojo going what are your
thoughts there I think it's exactly
right I mean the culture war that's been
raging in the country is really not a
war between the elites and the non
elites it's between the elitists and
everyone else people who think that jobs
being lost at the New York Daily News is
a national tragedy but jobs being lost
in the steel industry is totally fine
because those are a bunch of rubes in
the Rust Belt anyway what President
Trump really does better than virtually
any other politician on the American
scene is he he conveys that he really
does care about people who are in these
industries the people who are doing the
the so-called dirty jobs that people on
the coasts tend to think only illegal
immigrants are willing to do yeah been I
was I did my angle that tonight on the
Koch brothers who've done a lot of good
stuff on tax reform and supporting Brett
Kavanaugh and tax you know deregulation
excuse me they've done good stuff on
that but they are just adamant that even
discussing tariffs it's gonna crater the
global economy it's gonna be trouble
they have 60,000 or 65,000 workers
overseas they have 16,000 in the United
States but they have a lot overseas so
they're the old Republican Guard and
they want they don't like this and
they're gonna start funding some
Democrats because they want to fight
that Trump approach to trade well I
think obviously funding Democrats is not
the answer to this I'm a free trader
myself and I'm not particularly fond of
tariff policy but the real key here
again I think it's less policy driven
than it is even cultural the president
obviously has a lot of sympathy for
people who are in these industries that
that have paid a price due to trade I
mean there's no question that there are
winners and losers in trade overall I
think the trade is a great thing for the
United States I think free trade is a
great thing for the United States but to
pretend that there are no downsides to
trade is obviously not telling the whole
truth yeah well I mean I think that
again the results of the election and
those Rust Belt states and they suffered
the great job losses over the last 20
years of China being in the WTO I mean
it all these all these neocon Hawks been
who all they did is tell us you know we
got to build up the military gotta build
up the military that's great
I agree but China is the big threat to
the to America's dominance male
thoroughly and economically and so if we
just grow their economy at the expense
of our own we're gonna be in some
trouble down the road I also want you to
get you get some thoughts from you on
something that's kind of the opposite of
what that Chicago Sun Times columnist
wrote this was a piece published this
morning imagining the day after Trump's
re-election loss in 2020 okay here it is
as Trump sieved and tweeted in defeat
late Tuesday and president-elect
Elizabeth Warren celebrated the arc of
the Trump story is starting to make more
sense that has from much of his chaotic
presidency the normal rules of politics
do apply to Donald Trump after all so
now the time the time was up for Trump
they're already imagining his loss which
tells you well the derangement center
whatever you want to call it that cliche
is already wearing thin but they're now
having to write about 2020 in 2018 yeah
well then I think they're desperate to
take down president from right now they
are hoping obviously the 2016 was an
outlier and they're gonna blame it on
anything they'll blame it on Hillary
Clinton being a bad candidate finally or
they'll blame it on Russian collusion
which they've yet to prove but they what
they won't acknowledge that there's a
systemic problem inside the Democratic
Party and screaming Medicare for all and
running a Hillary Clinton clone like
Elizabeth Warren is not going to fix the
giant gap that they have with the middle
of the country whom they still consider
a bunch of bitter clingers working jobs
they would never deign to get their
hands dirty doing listen I'm a guy who's
from the coast where I'm from LA I spent
some of my time in Cambridge
Massachusetts I am an elite by any of
these standards but the bottom line is
that the people in the middle of the
country are doing work that is as
important or more important than the
people on the coast who are sitting in
their coffee houses writing scripts well
but you don't you know you're not
necessarily an elite just because you go
to those nice institutions if you
understand the plight of the regular
working person and you think that they
have a role in our economy
you're not only you're someone who went
with elitist and I think Trump actually
made this distinction Ellie recently he
said listen the countless audiences in
this audience are either good at your
job if you work hard if you do well
militates you are an elite by any
standard but you're not an elitist and
that's where the Democrats get it wrong
all right being an elitist is the
important thought advance repair